let's go to the phones the phone number
is 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we are going to go
to our caller from the three four seven
area code caller from three four seven
can you hear me tell us your name where
you're calling from I'm calling from New
York City all right what's on your mind
Brian I just wanted to know like how do
you feel about all like as far as like
the internet cause like how people
respond to each other not really knowing
who's sitting behind their computer or
their or their or their phone like we
don't really know that is anybody so how
do you feel about how people are
engaging on internet not knowing exactly
who they're talking to what they really
stand for and what their politics are
like sorry so about that I don't have a
problem with that the fact that the
Internet provides some anonymity I think
the problem is when people start to
believe that they're that they know
exactly who they're talking to right I
mean I think it's the right thing to
realize hey I could be talking to anyone
the problem is and where most of the
problems come up in terms of people
getting scammed or catfished or whatever
else is that they think that they know
exactly who they're talking to when they
really don't you know what I mean
right like it kind of struck me as odd
recently like a few weeks ago and I
voted for Donald Trump I never imagined
that I could possibly be engaging with
like a Russian on the internet who was
trying to pretend that they're American
and the racist they hate like I'm a hate
gay people like I just had to stop
engaging with people on the internet all
together but wait do you know for a fact
that you were engaging with a Russian
pretending to be at rumpus know you
might have something I I don't know so
that's why I just don't engage
altogether like if they don't have like
a verified check mark or like if it's
not like I kind of like yours why see
you every day on YouTube and you know
you send out links if it's not like that
then I just assume they're Russian
weren't there some some of it weren't
they're actually verified Twitter
accounts that it turned out were
actually like fake Russian personas I
don't know if that's true Pat but I
remember so no I don't think so
I don't know
verified accounts being fake well be
careful out there if if that beautiful
woman or man says that they just came
across your profile and they really want
to meet and they're incredibly wealthy
you got to be a little skeptical right
Brian I think that's the takeaway you
know what David look at night all right
have a good one uh Brian Brian did not
like my joke there clear all in good fun
not the right joke for Brian that's for
sure